c'est pas si vous avez remarqué j'ai la
rentrée aujourd'hui il y a toujours une
phrase que te dit ton père quand tu
arrives à l'école la veille il va aller
tâcher les baskets parce que tu vas
toujours acheter des baskets avec ton
baron la veille de la rentrée et ton
père te dit cette phrase qui n'a rien à
voir j'espère qu'avec ces baskets tu vas
bien travailler à l'école
[Applaudissements]
quel rapport mon frère mais moi je lui
dis rapport j'ai peut-être courir plus
vite mais c'est tout voilà non mais
c'est fou franchement c'est vrai et moi
je me rappelle la rentrée des classes
incroyable
de l'école la rentrée des classes tu
arrives tu sais quoi tu sais pas dans
quel cas tu vas te retrouver et tu
est-ce que je vais me retrouver dans la
classe de Mélanie Godin à la fameuse
moi je me rappelle j'avais fait allemand
juste pour être dans sa classe
[Rires]
c'est magnifique le premier jour tu fais
rien tu arrives déjà la tenue que tu vas
choisir pour la rentrée des classes elle
est très importante moi je me rappelle
très bien je me rappelle j'avais acheté
une chemise chez renifry avec ma mère
une année à carreaux jaune et noir une
bombe atomique on dirait une abeille
[Rires]
un truc de fou et les chéris et ben je
vais vous dire je suis arrivé je voulais
tellement la mettre mais il faisait
froid ce jour-là de la rentrée j'ai mis
un pull en laine en dessous j'ai mis la
chemise par dessus fermé
c'était magnifique non mais vraiment
magnifique non mais la rentrée des
classes incroyable je sais pas quel
point tu vas voir il y a toujours des
potes oh là là non [ __ ] j'ai journal
en histoire-géographie voilà elle fait
des interros surprises tous les
mercredis je suis dégoûté un message
il y a toujours un prof avec un collier
de barbes
ça c'est toujours et généralement le
gars a un nom de boisson il s'appelle où
Monsieur Fanta
et c'est vrai que il y a toujours un
gars comme as et avec une peuple
à l'ancienne et il était toujours les
profs qui sont là les autres profs et
lui il est un petit peu en retrait quand
même il regarde les feux programme
Hanouna tu vas en chier cette année
je m'appelle moi monsieur lot il avait
un truc quand il rendait les copies
c'était magique s'il faisait comme ça et
tu savais pas quelle note tu allais
avoir et il était quand même il avait la
main sur
[Rires]
Bouaziz c'est nul ça je fais aucun
effort toi 17
Hanouna c'est génial tu fais des gros
progrès 2
[Applaudissements]
c'était incroyable c'est incroyable
turbulent est-ce que les professeurs
vous appréciez malgré tout
l'élection des délégués bah oui je
voulais te déléguer de classe parce que
quand on parle moins mal de toi quand tu
as devant mon prof donc forcément je
voulais absolument être déléguer de
classe mais il a fallu que je magouille
donc en fait ce qu'on a fait j'étais
avec un pote Jalal j'embrasse tu es mon
meilleur pote à l'école et on avait
préparé des papiers avec que des Hanouna
vous allez bourré les yeux
donc un moment ils disent bon on va
faire les délégués donc il y a la prof
qui au tableau alors qui se présente
voilà Brisson Thomas Brisson un truc
Nicolas Gratien et Hanouna Hanouna se
présente oui il se présente donc là vous
notez sur un papier
personne pour qui vous votez qui veut
ramasser moi
ramasser on avait prévu il avait une
petite banane [ __ ] et il avait mis
tous les papiers et kaloula dedans donc
il ramassait pas pieds lui avait donné
une petite Corneille et un moment il
fait ce petit refuge j'y prends aimer
les papiers avec un dedans donc elle
arrive Hanouna
Hanouna
et je voyais dans la classe il commence
à avoir oui un ronronnement
et délégué de classe donc quoi qu'est-ce
qu'il y a vous allez faire un putsch
alors maintenant
je suis délégué vous allez faire quoi ça
y est il est papillon parler terminé
merci au revoir merci Madame on peut
commencer le cours s'il vous plaît
tous les ans ça fait tous les ans je
l'aurais fait la même toujours est-ce
que je faisais je le dis au
téléspectateurs parce que c'est rentré
des classes mais ne le faites pas comme
j'étais délégué de classe en fait
j'avais déjà le numéro de tous les
élèves est-ce que je faisais c'est que
j'avais quand je voulais pas aller en
cours en fait je regardais j'ai plein de
demandes à 2h de français à 8h je
sortais tous les soirs moi-même en
seconde tout ça donc je rentrais tard
flemme et tout j'appelais tous les
élèves ils disent ouais bon la prof de
français elle est pas là demain moi on
démarre à 10h
et en fait personne ne venait oh donc
forcément il y avait pas cours la prof
elle est arrivée elle dit il y a
personne donc on est arrivé tout à 10h
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah non je sais
pas
la prof était dit mais pourquoi
qu'est-ce que vous faisiez pourquoi vous
étiez malin je sais pas moi
je sais pas moi c'est eux mais voilà et
donc on démarre à 10h c'était magique
bah oui ça il faut le faire il y a
attendez vos petits camarades qui vous a
dit conneries un petit camarades un
petit camarade
mais j'étais tous très content il arrive
à 10h tranquille sans déconner mais moi
j'ai eu plein de trucs moi comme ça il y
avait un autre truc aussi moi entre les
interclasses je je notais sur la table
tout le si jamais un contrôle d'histoire
maintenant je notais tout le cours sur
la table
et moi est-ce que je faisais je mettais
la table au premier rang je dis je suis
tranquille je suis au premier rang je
suis sage je suis tout seul il y avait
des gens qui pouvait se mettre à côté de
moi non non tu avais qu'à apprendre
le pire c'est qu'un jour je vous jure
que c'est vrai j'arrive je suis
tranquille à ma table la prof arrive
elle fait comme ça
dernier
rond
j'ai rien fait je suis comme ça je suis
tranquillement en train de je prends la
table avec moi
[Applaudissements]
et quand tu triches à l'école il y a
toujours cette phrase quand tu te fais
cramer moi je me rappelle aussi
j'écrivais en tout petit j'avais plein
de feuilles et en fait j'ai trouvé un
tout petit au crayon tout le court et
donc j'avais un tas de feuilles comme ça
et quand tu te fais cramer tu te fais
toujours la même tête la prof arrive
elle te fait faites voir
ça couche-toi qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
j'emmène toi des surpris genre quelle
horreur mais c'est horrible ce qu'il a
fait madame tu l'as fait ça et là tu as
toujours pas moi c'est pas moi
maintenant ah oui c'est sûr
que vous recopiez tout le cours ça a été
plus rapide de l'apprendre mais alors
c'est ça mais bon moi je me rappelle moi
j'ai même tricher au bac français pardon
faut pas le faire bien sûr
c'est presque j'avais j'avais ce qu'on
appelle mais mais mes copains avaient
appelé ça la mallette magique j'avais
une mallette que j'avais pris à mon père
il avait une fausse manette Cartier
qu'il avait acheté au Tunisie
Bordeaux et c'était genre la mallette
diplomatique j'ai pris sa mallette quand
je lui ai demandé papa je peux prendre
ta mallette on dirait que je lui avais
pris un bras mon frère il était genre
c'était vraiment tu vois et je suis un
mec la mallette quartier
et j'avais et vous savez au bac français
vous avez des textes à apprendre et il y
a un livre pour nous un livre pour
l'examinateur et moi sauf que j'avais un
troisième livre donc en fait j'avais 30
livres dans ma vallée
et donc et j'avais une meuf j'embrasse
d'ailleurs Johanna Benaim qui m'a doré
qui m'avait écrit entre les lignes
toutes les toutes les explications de
texte c'est un quartier d'organiser
le texte très bien je balance au fond de
la classe je prends le livre où il y a
toutes les crimes après avant d'arriver
je change de livre j'arrive voilà le
livre voilà le livre après je commence à
discuter avec Samia qui examinatrice
parce que moi je veux faire du théâtre
[ __ ]
tu es un grand amateur de donjures
Lorenzaccio magnifique voilà et donc là
j'ai une très bonne note j'ai eu 14
c'est pas nul ça passe ça passe
oui oui ma mère a reçu les notes elle a
pas compris
non mais c'est vrai quoi qu'est-ce qu'il
y a l'énergie que vous avez mis à
tricher
très bien à la culture
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui devait se dire votre papa
j'avais écrit j'avais écrit un jogging
de mon père j'étais très grand donc j'ai
pris très large à mon père et j'avais
noté tout le cours dessus
et tout le contrôle j'étais comme asse
un moment je ne voyais tellement rien
sans déconner j'ai dit allez vas-y
nikomo que je rends la copie j'ai eu
zéro alors et moi ce que je faisais
aussi je sais pas parce que ça a rentré
des classes je faisais des enquêtes sur
les profs c'est-à-dire que j'avais par
exemple un prof prof de physique par
exemple et qu'est-ce que je faisais
je lui disais oui non j'enquêtais pour
voir dans quel lycée il était avant
qu'est-ce que je faisais j'allais dans
le disseau il était avant j'allais à la
sortie et je disais est-ce que vous avez
eu par exemple monsieur Richard l'année
dernière
et un moment j'ai trouvé une meuf qui
avait eu monsieur Richard je lui ai dit
bah je te rachète tous les contrôles que
tu as fait l'année
et en fait il avait changé de lycée il
faisait les mêmes contrôles il avait
fait l'année dernière dans le lycée où
il était donc en fait moi je préparé le
contrôle chez moi
j'arrivais et short et la feuille
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait il faisait les
mêmes contrôles mais changer des doses
ça veut dire quand il disait 28 ml de de
plus plus moi chez nous c'était 15 donc
il me rend ma copine je comprends pas
tous les raisonnements sont bons mais
tous les jours
et
voilà
pour venir la brutique GT maintenant
le coup il y a une vraie gamberge pas
j'étais une vraie banane
qu'il fallait faire ça c'est pas bon
j'allais voir les profs je leur disais
en difficulté j'ai rien prendre des
cours en plus etc je cherche un prof ou
de ne pas des cours et tout ouais ouais
donc je faisais venir le prof à la
maison et en fait j'avais prof il me
faisait faire les contrôles avant qu'il
fasse en classe
une année j'avais que des 18 en
physique-chimie ah ouais je sortais la
feuille pareil
merci voilà mais ça c'est magnifique
c'est votre truc ça ah ouais j'adore la
fiction
ne le faites pas surtout ne le faites
pas mais c'est tentant quand même
moi j'étais en rassera je ne dormais pas
de la nuit quand j'avais un contrôle au
lendemain ah oui je trouvais tous les
moyens pour savoir comment j'allais
faire pour m'en sortir
parce que en fait le seul truc pour
lequel je travaille bien c'était pour
faire plaisir à ma mère bien sûr et en
fait ce que je faisais moi je sais que
je refaisais les copies ça veut dire un
contrôle où j'ai eu deux je refaisais
toute la copie je corrigeais moi-même la
copie avec un stylo rouge montrer à ma
mère j'ai eu 17 Marie bah oui c'est
normal donc en fait
dans ma chambre et elle cherche un truc
dans mon sac et elle a trouvé au fond de
la au fond du cartable toutes les notes
2 3
[Applaudissements]
maman je vais réussir non mais non mais
l'histoire est vrai l'histoire travaille
bien à l'école ouais très bien
l'école c'est l'école de la vie
travaille très bien mais soyez pas
devenus politicien avec un tel sens quoi
merci Isabelle